Where will your next
customers come from?
I'll give you a hint.
It's inside this circle.
Plus, Firefox Performance
Tools get a major overhaul.
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is Lazy Web.
Emerging markets are expected
to add billions of new users
to the web, so
how do we prepare?
Bruce Lawson of Opera
highlights the top domains
from around the world
and demonstrates
that everyone wants
the same internet
but not all networks
are created equal.
Covering topics like installable
web apps, responsive images,
and proxy browsers,
it's an eye opening look
at the future of the platform.
You can grab the link
down in the Show Notes.
The Accessibility
Cheat Sheet takes
some of the pain out of
making your site accessible.
Based on the Web Content
Accessibility Guidelines,
the cheat sheet gives
checklist examples
for features your site should
support and also provides
visual examples and
links to useful tools,
such as Lea Verou's
Contrast Ratio Checker.
Statistics show that 85% of
US retailers' mobile traffic
is on the web and it accounts
for 90% of their revenue.
Alex Komoroke and
Elisabeth Morant
explain the three selling
points of the web platform--
reach, performance,
and engagement--
in this talk from Google I/O.
The talk features high level
explanations of new features,
like install banners
and notifications,
as well as data
demonstrating the size and
financial impact of the web.
Take a look at the latest
DevTools in Firefox Developer
Edition.
Waterfall View highlights
frame rate changes
and corresponding
events on the timeline,
such as heavy JavaScript work.
The Call Tree summarizes
which functions eat up
the most time in
your application,
and the Flame Chart
helps you decide
if a function took a
very long time to run
or may have just been
called too many times.
This video also highlights
using Web Workers to speed up
your application.
You can check out the link
down in the description.
Decreasing network
latency with HTTP2
will make the entire web faster.
Ilya Grigorik's slides from
this year's Velocity Con
look at the ways that
HTTP2 will radically
change how we build
performant applications.
Stop concatenating
your resources
and focus on better caching,
remove domain sharding,
and let server push replace your
current inlining strategies.
You can see the full slide
deck down in the Show Notes.
That's it for this week, folks.
Links to everything are
down in the Show Notes.
Click that little
Subscribe button.
And to you Lazy Webers out
there, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]